the law describes these vulgar
militiamen as lean filthy mean but worst
of all is that they're short for in the
lands between the small are looked down
upon literally and so this hated race of
beings were doomed to live in shame to
make up for their size they banded
together and as these despised
mercenaries For Hire they will use any
dishonest tactic to get the upper hand
on their opponent the two largest
militia groups are in caled where they
guard grunk and the Forbidden lands
before the Black Blade Kindred who
serves Malakoff and so using techniques
bestowed upon them by the shadow of
America herself the short folk reveal
their usefulness as undecorated stewards
of the rancid scorched Battlegrounds
that the golden order wishes could be
excised from memory there are even
rumors that they use their serrated
weapons to cut up and cannibalize bodies
but you have to wonder is this true or
is it just another piece of
discrimination that keeps them
desperately in service to others